gonorrhea is a common type of sexually
transmitted disease or infection
it's sometimes referred to by the slang
term the clap
the germs that cause the infection are
tiny bacteria called niceria gonorrhea
you can catch gonorrhea from an infected
person during vaginal anal or oral sex
and if a pregnant woman has gonorrhea
she can pass it to her baby as the baby
moves through the birth canal during
childbirth
in your body the infection begins when
the bacteria attached to cells in the
tissue that lines many of your body
cavities called mucosal epithelium
once attached the bacteria begin to
invade this tissue
as the bacteria multiply over time and
damage your cells they cause immune
cells to enter the tissue
this inflames and damages the tissue as
your immune cells try to clear the
infection unfortunately the bacteria
have ways to avoid being eliminated by
your immune cells this allows the
bacteria to grow and spread within your
body
the main risk for getting gonorrhea is
having oral anal or vaginal sex with a
person who's infected
you may have a higher risk if you're
sexually active and have more than one
sex partner or a teenager or young adult
or are a man who has sex with men
many people have no symptoms but if a
woman has symptoms they may include an
abnormal discharge from the vagina
vaginal bleeding between periods and a
burning feeling while urinating a man
may have similar symptoms such as an
abnormal discharge from the penis a
burning feeling at the tip of the penis
or while urinating
and pain in one or both testicles
in both men and women gonorrhea may also
infect the rectum which is the last part
of the large intestine
symptoms of infection in the rectum may
include itching or abnormal discharge
from the anus and pain during bowel
movements
left untreated the infection may cause
pelvic inflammatory disease in women
this means the infection has spread
throughout her reproductive organs in
men it may lead to epididymitis this
refers to inflammation and swelling of
the coiled tube attached to the
testicles called the epididymis
the good news is that gonorrhea can be
treated successfully with antibiotics
such as Ceftriaxone you may also be
prescribed as second antibiotic such as
doxycycline to treat possible infection
with another sexually transmitted
disease called chlamydia people who have
gonorrhea are often infected with
chlamydia at the same time it's
important to know that treatment may not
fix any damage the disease has already
done to your body
after treatment it's important to follow
up with your doctor to confirm the
infection has cleared because some
bacteria have become resistant to
antibiotics
you can reduce your risk of getting
gonorrhea if you only have sex with one
long-term partner who doesn't have sex
with other people and who has been
tested for gonorrhea and doesn't have it
and you can practice safer sex which
means taking steps before and during sex
to prevent you from getting or spreading
gonorrhea for example using condoms
correctly every time you have sex can
reduce your risk the most reliable way
to avoid getting gonorrhea is to
practice abstinence which means not
having vaginal anal or oral sex
to find out more about gonorrhea talk to
your Healthcare practitioner